然后接下来的话介绍一下我们的两家合作主管然后其他楼的话全称是T技术沙龙然后是一个隐促进开发者针技术家里有回目的的一个技术沙龙组成立之会一直在定期举办观众面与开发者的现在剩下的沙龙活动然后但应该很回性了对老司机技术的话是一个有移动端计算号的组成另一个团铁但他们现在已经不仅是做移动端了至于在就是那种创造出更多的一些精品内容
然后也是近几年WWDC内餐的系列活动的主制者包括今年WWDC2 Playground他们也有参与对啊非常棒的一个主制好然后接下来我们把时间交给you然后让他让他陪大家一起看大山吧对好对好那么请ef把视角切过来呗好切到你了好好好谢谢谢谢这个牛啊牛啊啊
然后今天就是我刚才已经自我介绍了啊我教育了然后接下来我们就会针对一些问题展开一些讨论今天是砸弹然后其实大家有什么问题可以提啊可以提然后直接我们就开始开始问题吧大幕可以随时提问哦然后第一个问题啊是ef之前提了就是去北之前对北京的印象
其实我本来是一个南方长大的同学大学没有在北方上然后其实到北京之前的北京没有什么贡献因为没有什么没有什么印象啊因为这个天高皇帝远对吧而且也不是学什么政治地理啥的就是个学理工科的其实对北京没有什么没有什么印象那这个ef呢你应该也是一个南方的这个人吧
啊对的我是哦家是无锡的嘛然后其实我也一直在南方那其实我有去过北方然后反正怎么说呢我我我我土生土长南方人然后之前可能就是一些就是做项目吧反正就是也是工作上了然后去北京然后又过一次旅游的经理然后去了之后留了三天鼻血对哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
其实最后还挺适应的我在这边为什么要强调人啊为什么要强调人不然说什么呢北京的同学北京的同事然后下个问题就是在北京这么长时间有没有觉得很棒的地方其实我刚来的时候就其实我先介绍一下我自己的工作经济好吧我到北京的时候其实是先是去百度的然后百度嘛因为在这个后厂村就无款外就之前
在北京在百度的两年一直都在五方外啊就几乎没有进过城啊所以那几年对北京其实是没有实感的就是就是感觉自己不在北京然后后来到19年之后就跳槽到林静颖然后就搬到城里了就搬到城里一下子其实感觉还蛮不一样的被竟然适应了北京这么干嗯对他干但是其实干干不是一件坏事就是
干燥其实大量的很多便利的比如说你一些打湿的地方它很快会自己干就不会发霉南方你可能地板上有点水它会坏掉它那个水不会很快蒸发其实干燥不是什么特别坏的事情而且这几年空气也变得非常不错然后感觉就是我鼻炎也好了我还挺适应这个气候的皮肤不用保养的吗没有保养
然后大城市的话就他还有个好处就是公平性啊什么都比较好就是比较讲规矩吧各种各种地方然后就是比如说你你外卖啊快递啊你要去投诉啊投诉都是有效的他不送上门你去投诉其实是真的有效的但是好像我在老家好像有的时候投诉没有这么有用然后不太适应的地方我说我觉得北京的外卖实在太难吃了就是美食荒漠啊真的是为什么好吃啊北京可以
可以通分把普通葡萄变葡萄干吗没有试过没有试过好吧只能说菜不会坏只会干坏还是会坏的就是没有看菜这个真的看菜就是有的有的菜有的菜能保存很久对好吃哎卢主啊你喜欢吃那种其实我不太喜欢吃这个内脏类的东西觉得比较那啥就内脏类吃的比较少然后
大概就这些吧总体就感觉大城市包容性还是好一点小城市其实有些地方非常排外的就是会比较难受然后所以所以你去爬了几次长城我没有去爬过长城国美大厦长城不是去北京避兴的吗我没有吧如果你说的是我谢谢谢谢孙先生的蜡条啊还有谢谢刚才刚才刷过去了那个那个同学蜡条谢谢
然后长城是因为长城有很多嘛八达岭我们说的一般都是八达岭是吧那其实还有很多像什么穆田鱼啊水长城啊古水北镇其实全部都有长城我爬过两个长城吧但我没有爬过八达岭就是广义上的长城没有没有爬过不到长城非好汉你要知道长城离这多远啊好远好远啊对一般一般很少会去的离市中心可能有六七十公里啊特别特别远我咋没去啊
这不是爬到差不多吧藏神都差不多吧木田与藏神是最吵的对然后啊木田与其实我也没有去过我大概倒过今天提总露脸吗今天不露脸这就是我这就是我好吧这就是我我自己辣条谢谢PK一票呀呃然后大概就是些吧要不下个下个问题是啊是什么契机能去领英啊这个
好问题好吧我到零一七是19年19年当时在百度我当年其实特别想出国然后特别想去日本然后我还当时还考了个拖业拖业就是日本那边看中的一个英语考试当然也学了考学一点日语好吧然后当年在百度的时候就觉得时间啊有点不太够用就时间被完全的挤压了好吧就是因为下班比较晚嘛下班都9点多了就9点多可能互联网上
这个还不算特别晚了但但你如果晚上想学点东西已经完全不够了然后就想着哎那怎么办呢怎么办呢一个是我当时就直接在公司反抗知道吗就是就是就是一到晚上啊吃完晚饭我就拿着书直接找个会议室去去看书去了我就我就不管了就就然后后来觉得这样不行啊后来就找外企找外企找着找着后来我是在linking的app里面找到了linking的工作所以还是听
挺巧妙的所以这个契机总结来说就是觉得时间不够你又想干点别的事情那怎么办呢我就找个外资对大概简单的就是这样烂没面上对我当时面了烂了就是没有面上当时是网册网册过了然后然后还有个鄙视啊当时那个鄙视他给了提示太多了做不完然后然后后来就挂了刚才那个是瞄神对的对的
对现在现在有很多这个外似的猎头什么的大家如果呃那啥有有这方面的想法可以关注一下因为最近这个疫情搞的大家很多的work remote对吧就变成工作了其实外似是个挺不错的选择吧ef怎么怎么觉得呢有没有什么想发表的我觉得能听外似的话当然是挺好的啦但是
这个东西的话就是就可能不是就因为因为这个就又涉及到一个你的个人的只有一个规划或者是说你找工作希望找一个什么样的去处啊反正就不是单因素影响但可能有很多人他非常坚定的说哎唯有一个目标我就是希望出国或者说我就是希望去外企然后有机会能够在呃exchange到国外对吧就就
这个样子的话当然就是也挺好的对所以我觉得就是对于外企的话就不是能一样定的就是说你有一个就是固定的看法或者怎么样因为因为有比如说像你前面讲你有很多人可能去外企就是说以后有机会去国外或者说至少外企可能就相当于说你在国内体验国外的一个工作感受然后是怎么样但可能包括我认识的可能另外一些朋友他有很多都比如说去合肥
然后也是去了外企然后就还顺便回了老家因为他老家就合肥就就就像这样的就是二三件城市或者是新一件城市对这样也是挺好的嘛所以就就反正就是各种因素都会有对ok ok刚才苗审说彼氏可以提前告诉我那你总你怎么不早说你怎么不早说呢哈哈哈苗审是故意来谢谢你
谢谢超斯拉的牛啊 大家这个理性消费好吧理性消费 谢谢打口啊 谢谢然后下一个问题就大家如果有什么看法可以弹幕打出来如果我看到我会我会大概回一下对如果太多刷过去了可能就错过了 好吧 谢谢啊讲的爱了 然后下个问题啊灵魂和国内公司有什么不同
嗯就不同不同年期是蛮多的海因为首先啊这个工作市场我我可以给大家稍微讲一下我们现在工作的这个节奏啊其实我们现在自从疫情啊就是20年之后一直是remote就是也不是算remote就是属于混合制的啊hybrid的的一个工作形式然后基本上嗯前面的一年肯定都是一直在这个原成的
然后后面稍微好了点之后就恢复成一半一半就是一周去个两天这样然后这个也是动态调整的就是根据现在这个疫情的情况和国内的政策进行动态的调整所以其实大部分时间都在这个都在都在家里对然后所以一个工作时长你会受到一些很大的变化首先你会发现通情这个事情通情这个事情从在生命中消失了
谢谢极速的灯牌两个还有点多通勤这个东西一旦消失之后你一天的时间就变长了可能你原来通勤要花一个小时到两个小时在北京的话你起码得两个小时吧就来回然后现在你一天多出两个小时这两个小时你拿来干什么都好对吧然后你可以拿来工作你也可以拿来干别的然后如果你拿来干别的相当于你的工作时长就缩短了
然后相对也是自由一点嘛就我 from home嘛对吧就大家大家办公然后然后说到这个我还要再提一下就是其实我们你在家工作就是你得买一些东西对吧你可能要买办公桌办公椅我们叫home office就是你要在家里建设一个office那这个东西是有成本的我们公司会提供提供了一定的这个经费啊就大概一共加起来可能给差不多一万块钱吧就是你可以买一些
买一些你想要的桌子啊椅子啊显示器啊等等这些办公的用具就你买然后公司给你报销谢谢谢谢礼物谢谢bikala好吧谢谢bikala谢谢辣条呀然后然后对说到这个就home office然后然后就是还有些其他的这个福利啊就比如说我们有个叫per cup的就是一个
一个怎么说的一个福利项目就是说你可以每一年有大概六千块钱啊六千就就一千刀吧六千六千块钱你可以拿去干一些比如说按摩啊这种消费啊或者说你想做一些资讯比如说财务资讯啊你你的这个有一些钱你想怎么处理有一些收费的这个财务资讯你是可以花的然后比如说宝杰就你请那个宝杰的
宝杰的这个阿姨来家里打扫这些都是可以报销的对就有这么一个ProCup的福利项目包括还有其他的假期比如说LiftUp我们叫LiftUp这个福利是最近才出的还是挺厉害的七月到八月两个月时间每周休息半天然后其他的日子就每周日
就其他的日子就是每个月会有一个周五整天放假就是有这种其他的这个放假的福利啊就特别多就休假到休假到这个麻木了都快然后那当然还有其他的比如说我们这个叫什么圣诞节啊圣诞节也是有假期的因为全公司放假嘛就shout down嘛就整个公司都关了也不能说关了就是大家都放假对然后有大概
10天左右吧就额外假期其实非常多了就是基本上基本上基本上就是就是特别多然后还有一点就是结文化啊这个我想着重讲一下就其实其文化对一个人的影响非常大今天这是人画修到麻木那有的时候我们确实有种感觉啊就包括我们还有一种叫no meeting day的就这一天你不许开会
这一天是给你写单吧或者是给你recharge充电了你不允许开会有的时候你想干点什么有点事然后突然一抬头啊今天要弄meating day啊哇今天是什么lift up假期啊就有的时候还挺懵的然后回到这个有摸鱼对吗就不能说好吧就不好说话说回到结文化其实这一点能讲的特别多然后嗯
文化这一点其实在很深层次会影响一个员工的这个状态工作的状态就比如说我就我就提一个例子吧比如说像自己啊像自己他可能其实文化比较粗广一点就比较比较狂野一点是吧他拼命的加班然后想到一个东西一拍脑袋
组一个team去做然后做做做做你疯狂做掉头发做最后最后最后上不了或者死了这种项目非常多那员工其实也很痛我们的合作方有字节吗我不知道好那就没关系如果有的话对不起就是做个对比做个对比就因为字节比较典型嘛对不对然后然后然后外企其实他
不太一样就他会更注重比如说的一个人作为一个人他是有情绪的就是你让他一直做一个东西最后不上线然后他其实是会难受的是吧就你做了坑车坑车做了一个多月熬夜熬的这一生梦死最后连上线都上不了或者说上了一下就下来了像这种其实人是会有情绪的然后各种方面其实你得
作为管理层他是要去考虑这些事情的但好像国内公司关注这方面的并不多但在铃银他会重视这一方面的体验吧就是让你让你字节白温白参团就是让你过得稍微舒服一点对吧就是不要把人当做一个机器一样就是不停的工作你有人的需求对吧你要休息你要
你要充电你要摸鱼对吧摸鱼其实也是一个需求然后不能说剥夺了这个人的权利对所以这个企业文化就是定义的管理层他会不会去关注这些方面的东西所以我感觉文化是一个很影响人的一个东西对这个点能看直播的都不是字节对我们说的是那个供应商啊不是供应商叫什么赞助商啊如果有赞助商是字节我们就
那收回我刚才的话好了爸爸不能得罪OK那就下一个喽严肤有什么想发表的吗嗯你是说现在这个问题吗嗯对我你切到下一个问题了吗我没有看到啊没有那我切到下一个吧好下一个问题有的公司文化是开水是的是的
可以说某天下个问题是跨时计零一还有HC吗这个好像后面有问题我们现在客户端没有HC这个问题后面有后面在讲吧目前没有HC然后下个问题是跨时计沟通跨时计会遇到这些问题这个遇到问题其实大家很好遇见一个是时间不合对吧特别是跨时计特别是跨到美国这种要不就一方熬夜要不就一方早起谢谢阿拉阿拉阿里加多
谢谢牛娃 谢谢牛娃 谢谢牛娃做一个我最近遇到的吧之前跟跟一下日本的公司约了一个online meeting对吧日本不是没有几乎没有时差吗几乎没有时差吗就一个小时对对对就是几乎没有时差但是我还真的就踩到了这个坑他给我发了一封邮件上面有一个online meeting的预约然后我很认真的对了时间还射了闹钟然后
然后到了时间之后我发现我那个爽约了然后对方就问我为什么然后我再回头看了一下邮件上面写的是gstok 那是不是你你没有用一些这个calendar就日历的管理工程他不会自动的帮你去预定你这个时间段对我没有这个时候你肉眼肉眼看还是容易看错的对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对对
所有的东西都会看注意看时期 注意看时期如果要肉眼看的话对然后跨时期如果像业服说这种情况就是时期都看错了啊就如果你是真的跨了很大的时期对 描写说的你跨国工作多一些就会注意时期了其实我们不太注意吧因为都是Kallen的自动帮你book到这个
对应的时间就有会有生成一个代办事项之类的就不需要肉肉身换算因为美国他那边还有下令是什么的区别肉身换算其实很难对对对需要日历这种软件蓝辅助对如果你真的跨到美国这种时期了肯定是首先就算你时期看着了你肯定会遇到熬夜或者早起的问题就我之前我的Mantra是在美国的然后我我会有跟他一个例行的 one one就一对一的这么一个
会然后我每次都是我七八点钟起来然后他那边是下午快下班的时候就只能这样子才能对上或者是我们这边早一点他们那边晚或者他们那边早一点我们这晚一点只能这个样子然后如果你是做一些分享你就做一些分享如果你要考虑让美国的团队来听的话那我们基本上安排在早上九点或者九点半或者十点就根据动力时下令是不同
你们两个team只能在一个很小很小的时间窗口里比如说一天只有半个小时或者一个小时的窗口参加沟通不然的话要么人家下班了要么你睡觉要么人家下班了这就是跨国会遇到的问题大家就沟通效率低但是你说这个问题没有办法解决其实没有什么办法解决除非你不跨国对吧你一旦要跨国这个问题它一定是会存在的
你快点升职就能换成对面熬夜了那人家是我的matter呀那我导的matter肯定比我高嘛我你这话说的倒是没有问题你说的这个倒是没问题然后对一个就是这个实在的问题啊还有就是沟通上的问题啊沟通上的问题也很简单好谢谢你啊谢谢你啊离境交费哦还有一个就沟通上的问题就是听不懂吗对吧这个特别是一些口音相对重的一些同事
有的时候就真的听不懂听不懂听不懂的情况呢他其实又分为两种啊一种是你可以听不懂的情况就比如说你是个sink hub是一个同步的密切你只要说你干了什么或者某些问题处理好了没有就这样就可以了有一些会议是你必须要跟对方交流比如说你出来个bug你要跟人家一起调这是两种情况如果是第一种情况那其实人家
说什么你听不懂问题不大就你管你自己说说完你想说的其实就ok了对吧但第二种情况就比较尴尬了就是有一些同事你跟他调bug然后你们互相又听不懂这个事情怎么办呢就我们这边只能就是喊manager过来当翻译就带个人啊拓家带口的就带个manager就没有办法嘛对吧直接说印度对就因为印度的同事多嘛对吧
肯定是印度的同事就是遇到的会这种情况比较多一方面是因为你如果跟美国的同事那其实他们的口音是比较标准的你是很容易听懂的很容易沟通的然后如果那当然就是印度的同时他可能才才有可能会遇到这种状况对那那我其实没有什么办法就是我们那只能脱上manager就这个ef有什么想说的吗爱因人士表示不满拿啥
爱印人是好吧印度英语还好吧是我比较好些就是你比如说你现在就是在工作当中就是用外语直接就是不是通过打字就是直接语音跟别人沟通这样的就是需要多吗不是特别多就这个不是特别多分成好几个方面啊一个是你合作的team如果你是个中国人
对方大概率会派一个中国人过来跟你沟通就其实中国在中国的人在美国那边做程序员非常非常多的就可能每个team都好久中国人一方面是这种情况还有就是说就我说的是Zincub meeting你说你自己做了啥更新了啥就行了就其实真正遇到调bug这种场景还是不是特别多的因为这不可能三天两头总出bug吧对吧我看一下你们弹幕
铃银的英语要求高吗做Eng的话就做工程设法其实还好不是特别高面试考算法是留小作业不会留小作业了不会留小作业了一般都是当场作业好吧算法多算法多这个后面有一个问题到时候再详细讲吧就是你们问了我可以先回答一下对我在外企我也在外企一整天和美国人三次回忆这个刚才那个那个mms
我想插一下因为这个话题我其实挺想找一下的因为我现在虽然我们不是要跨国其实也算是要跨国公司吧我现在呼拉拉嘛但因为我们其实有一个国际化的线然后我现在刚好在做国际化的线刚才就是又讲的这个问题反正我也碰到过因为我们以前是有美国市场的然后我们当时我还是我刚进来的时候就是负责美国市场当时最怕的就是大半夜出试过
那不是航空我把你叫起来是吧对我记得最近有一个就是因为我平时都睡得很早然后突然有一天就那天我看到睡得比较晚然后12点的时候两个两个线上的EM然后我就当时随手就给处理掉了反正挺有意思的就是大湾业出问题对然后关于那个印度的那个确实也挺尴尬你说那个翻译你说拉着那个Engineer Manager去做翻译我昨天吧
刚好就干了这不件事就是我们有一个对有一个团队在内地嘛然后有一个工程师是印度的然后他们在群里面一个说一个打中文一个打英文完全听不懂然后说要开个会然后把我拉过去做翻译是的其实我想说印度的英文我也不是很听得懂说心理吧是印度英文其实分两种啊一种是长期在美国的那种印度英语
那个其实是多听能听懂的还有一种是在班加鲁啊就是在那个在在印度的印度同时有一些口音特别重就是不太好听懂那种不太好听懂是一个单词都听不懂那种就是记得顾虑一团不知道他说什么就是就是这种可能是我听的还不够多啊有描写可能听的相对还多一点挺尴尬的其实
所以这个时候manager的作用就出来了就这种情况manager得顶住你不能再去找senior manager去解决翻译这个事情所以后面如果做管理的同学如果要到外企做管理的英语这个东西是个坎真的是个坎日本英语和印度英语其实神似我们好像日本同事比较少没有和日本日本人的同事交流过因为我们在日本没有研发
我们在日本没有研发所以没有打的交道比较少刚才描写说客户端不存在值班其实我们是存在的因为我刚才开头说了我的垂垒方向有用户增长其实我现在大概在用户增长团队然后我们有很多比如说注册登录这种问题就注册登录其实后面涉及到的这个技术非常非常多就比如说最简单的你要发验证码验证码收不到怎么办然后
比如说触发了反作V不让你注册怎么办那其实这些系统很多都是在global的在美国那边所以就我们听不懂这种事还还蛮多的不过我我确实沟通的相对少一点东北人在印度而话音主要是中国人很多方言也听不懂但中国人一般沟通普通话吧对吧我我听不懂会等一下这滚过去了直接找同船啊标识你们那还有同船的吗可以啊
谢谢牛啊谢谢牛啊谢谢打口啊你敢懂zoom可以打开实施翻译对的zoom是有一个实施翻译的实施字幕的这个功能但它翻译出来的英文这个根本没法看啊就翻译的很烂啊这这哪看得懂啊反正我们用的是看不懂的就不可读好吧他虽然有这个功能但是不可读对teams也很早就有了但是我觉得不可读
我们是在日本的韩国公司同船是标配那太羡慕你们了专人专事了这个还挺好的现在还写UI 8层吗你做IOS吗8层肯定是要写的你不写8层谁来写8层你作为IOS工程师你不写8层谁帮你写8层对吧写的这个问题大家还有什么想说的可以发挥说Lac翻译很流没有用过来我也没有用过
零Swift看應該你應該打了一半我們繼續吧公司團隊技術氛圍這是一個很大的話題其實我在零這幾年經歷了整個團隊技術氛圍的變遷其實我19年來的時候團隊一個是人還沒有這麼多還有個就是整個其實管理的結構跟現在不太一樣我剛來的時候其實很多秩序很多規則還沒有建立起來
然后现在到现在三年多了然后很多规范都建立起来了就显得好很多所以大家其实平时在公司如果觉得自己公司制度有些问题的话可以去尝试推动一下或者尝试把他问题找出来然后让manager怎么样的去推动一下就现在我们那儿有其实整个都比较规范了比如说你想做一个什么项目
那你会先写文档那肯定是先写文档所以我们叫RFCreviewRequest for comments你先让大家来comment然后就是你想做一个什么样的东西然后用了拿几种技术选情然后技术选情分别有什么优缺点这些东西你都列清楚然后其他的这个同事会来comment会来评价就是你比如说某个点你没有讲清楚或者某个技术方案有哪些不好的地方他会给你comment然后你就在那解决
等你把大家的这个评论啊都解决的差不多了之后这个你可以说你想做的这个东西的技术方案可以敲定了就是大家团队的一些资深的工程师都没有意见了或者问题都解决了ok 你就可以开始做了然后的话呃当然排气啊后面还有排气什么的资源什么的跟pm 这个抢时间啊这个当然也是存在的然后等你做完之后呢会有call review对吧我们的call review其实是非常的严格
就是我们比如说晋升的时候啊他会看这个code review的数量和质量特别是那些你在你不能说进去一个一个一个这个code review一个rv我们叫review board一个一个request你就你就直接shape啊直接通过look to me就这种多了是不好的这样这样多了是没有用的就这种属于基本上属于无效的这种review然后
有一个相对比较严格的review然后你要解决所有的comment然后包括你在提代码机前会跑增花测试啊这些都流程都是集成在ci里的嗯我看一下有个朋友评论了说需求文档质量就是文档质量怎么样啊你问怎么样这个我很难回答呀那怎么样我说好呢我很难就是你可以问一些更加细节的问题就更加具体的问题你这个我有很难回答就
我接着说回了就是call review会比较严格然后等你把那些review都可以都解决完然后shape之后你就可以入库对吧然后当然还有一些做实验什么的这等等就该有的其实现在都有了然后我们的所有的讨论基本上都是在slack里完成的就之前其实我刚来的时候我们还没有见slack的这个就是就
就是中国这边的slag群然后也是近期才慢慢建起来的然后包括一些技术分享啊就这种这种都是都是有的所以技术范围其实是挺ok的稍等我看一下你们的弹幕有没有用跨平台的框架现在没有现在没有这个后面有个问题后面有个类似的问题你可以接着听Ut的覆盖率啊覆盖率
我不知道这能不能说我们的目标是75一个比较通用的标准Ut90%这不现实吧有些东西你Ut测不了Test它是分Ut还有比如说Layout的然后还有Scenario的就是测你是要点点点的那种就是分好几种Test我们整体的Ut要求是75可能你要测的那些你可以达到90比如说某个东西它是可以用Ut去测的然后
你那个文件达到90%这是完全ok的但是你说整体的话整体的90我觉得不太现实不太现实然后还有一点要说的其实就是我们这个我们项目里一些技术的迭代非常非常多就我们叫技术叫migration吧叫技术迁移吧可以说比如说你有个新的架构啊你需要写到app那你不可能一口气把你现有整个app重写是吧
然后你可能会在某一个模块里先这个尝试你的新架构然后还有一个这个一个实验开关可以切然后你的app里就会有这种比如说一个一个功能做了两套然后切来切去然后这样其实其实很很平常对吧国内公司也会这么做但我们恐怖的是这种实在是太多了就一个app里肯定有七八个这种这种七八个这种架构在
都在ramp都在实验所以特别特别多然后当然这个我觉得有好有好有坏吧对吧你对业务来说无非就是其实是有冲击的这对rupple其实真的有点乱就是你在写一个写这个模块的时候和在写另一个模块的时候他们两个甚至架构都长得完全不一样我靠你真的有时候写才很痛苦然后就对业务我觉得是其实是有有有害的你容易牵一出bug
但对工程师来说肯定是技术实力上是在技术上其实是有好处的七八个还好我指的七八个不是七八个实验我指的是七八个大的架构比如说你一个是MVC一个是MVDM一个是什么我们叫Nature有的叫就是这种级别的前移或者你有个新的网络库
这边用这个网络库那边用那个网络库然后你在同时RAM就是是这种级别的潜移不是不是一个功能在那边切对所以还是比较恐怖的就对我们整个维护其实比较痛苦ok ok下一个问题下一个问题你出了问题其实都有点难我觉得工作中遇见最难的事情你感觉像个面试好吧你们觉得什么问题会比较难处理呢
我先看一下你们弯弯幕啊需求文档伺化到每个页面还是每个大功能需求文档啊那肯定是每个页面都会有文档啊然后有UI的这个文档啊还有Tracking的就是那些打点的这些文档肯定是细致越细致越好的所有的UI有用上嘛之前在这个Widgets里用了但现在
现在现在我们有个新的app正在发就是我们做了一个新的铃银正在ramp已经对外public ramp了但是可能只有10%所以可能大部分人还看不见behavior question什么意思还在用nsuel collection吗这个我不知道这个是infra就是foundation那些人做的网络库我不知道底层到底用的什么好吧ef你刚才想说啥我说这些问题都
比较开放性就没有什么标准答案之类的嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯嗯
然后然后造原子弹又是有用的然后你就是造就完了但其实最难的不是造原子弹而是你先要知道原子弹是能造出来的接下来造原子弹是有用的对稍等我切个歌这个歌怎么这么这么正能量呢所以所以工作中其实最难的问题就是你不知道做什么东西是有用的就是很多项目
就特别是你要生就像我现在我如果要生stuff的话其实都是要自己去发现一些问题是解决的就最难的就是找这个问题对今天宝杰八大问这样子吧工程工程是怎么组电话这个我能说一小时这个这个问题回答不了现在这个讲材太多了最大的挑战就是这种OKOK所以
所以就是最难的就是我刚才说的其实让你想你要做什么这一个项目能不能做花多少时间这些评估其实都是简单的对吧然后你真的去做其实也是简单的但关键就是你怎么挖掘到价值的点还有就是人啊人永远是最难的东西就比如说有时候公投路径很长就是你在处理人那关系的时候就像有一个同事在美国他老是不理你然后你又必须经过他你怎么办呢
这个其实也是很难去处理的你要不就找manager是吧你找你的manager发邮件给他manager那这样其实不太不太好就我们可能那啥叫relationship matters就你要关注同事和同事的relationship你不能直接对人家对吧就尽量不要这样所以人和人的关系其实比较比较难搞对
现在学OC现在不要学OC了OC学什么OC不要学了这个是来反串的ok反串的皮拉拉技术宅是你吗是我外企学历卡的言不言肯定言啊我们公司对学历卡的蛮严的对除非你是这个你特别是越到校招啊他对学校要求更高了因为我们公司在美国其实美国的零件也是很牛的就像我不知道你们认不认识那个冰霜啊就是双神
双40就以前也是个iOS的大神他现在应该是出去在读说是吧读是在哪个学校来着看那季梅龙对吧看那季梅龙然后好像连经营都没有给他面试几回的那件事就我们公司其实在美国是比较难的然后然后然后其实国内招聘的越往校招靠他的学校摔得更严格我看一下哈
现在每个Q都有RFC要求没事找事太难了对也不能说没事找事吧你要Promotion你要升职你就必然要找事做呀所以找事最难了对是一反哥吗不是一反哥什么是什么是一反哥有直级吗什么叫有直级吗有直级啊每个公司都会有直级啊211985吗我我我我不好说这个硬硬标准在哪硬标准在不好说那但肯定是越越牛逼越好的
对可以问我是什么大学毕业的吗我就不要问了我是个普通的二本好吧我来领盈纯粹是因为有大厂的背书因为我之前百度在之前中科医院可能大厂的经历稍微好一点OK那这个问题就来了我觉得你们大多数人就关心这个问题是吧就想加入领要做什么首先我要说明白就是我们公司现在国内没有iOS的HC啊就没有highcom啊然后
安卓的前阵子现在好像也没有了就backhand和AI之类的还有一点FC因为现在其实就因为疫情整个国际形势其实挺不好的大家都在裁员我们公司现在没有裁员已经我觉得算不错的所以HC其实收得平紧的对然后准备的内容我大概其实就是刷算法这个是逃不掉的我是这么认为的
算法他可能塞不出你是優秀的工程師還不是優秀的工程師但他一定能塞出來你是懶還是不懶這個其實很重要就是你你覺得啊這東西沒用我懶得去刷那還是不行的對就像高考啊他可能就真的你不需要很高的智商你考個一本不需要很高的智商但你肯定是勤奮的話就不懶的話能考個不做分數的我就是因為太懶了所以剛好考得得差好吧
假如薪水給你翻倍幸福感能增加多少哇這怎麼回答呀幸福感能增加一倍不止吧因為你的生活中有一些固定開銷啊就比如說房租啊什麼的如果翻倍的話你能剩下的錢給你更多啊這幸福感肯定翻倍不止吧對吧看重低學歷嘛低學歷好像好像還好吧如果你是碩士的話本科好像看不多重慶也沒崗位重慶我們只
国内只有北京有研发哦其他的地方没有研发上海也没有上海也没有对上海深圳都没有只有北京有研发铃琴的铃琴的算法考DP吗DP肯定我不能说肯定考因为出题有个题库大家都是不一样的然后DP肯定是就比较基本的一种算法的解决方案所以肯定是要会了对吧你不可能DP也不会你就来
你就要来面算法那肯定不行啊打工的薪水没啥用确实方便问一下我的年纪吗年纪啊我五年以上好吧五年以上但我年纪不大30岁以下工作五年以上好吧你们猜吧ls的算法对mobile engineer的这个算法会稍微就是没有肯定是没有算法杠高的和那个这个backhand的可能也稍微简单一点点
我不确定因为我们提库其实有个提库然后出题的都是面试官自己选的我觉得纯粹靠运气吧或者说你这个面试官他的喜好啊就有的人特别喜欢考DP有的人特别喜欢考图有的人喜欢考数是吧那那那不一样的对吧我在美国吗不在美国我在国内我在北京这个问题我能回答翻了4.5倍焦水焦的
大牢好吧大牢谢谢谢谢我爱O的爱了谢谢35岁真的会被踩吗中国哪知道我没到35的但是我我公司有很多年纪比较大的这个工程师就35岁这个问题这个问题很难很难很难那啥很难很难回答你知道吗因为总有35被踩的那还有35都不到被踩的那也有35到了也没被踩的
这取决于他这个人怎么样真的是硬人而已我觉得像喵神对吧他怎么也得猜呢你们说呢硬人而已吧好吧能看ef女装吗efef有人看你女装你要不换假衣服给喵神立flag吗我的女装我之前在朋友圈回答过了呀这是不花钱就能看的内容吗
要花钱懂了好 上个提督吧你再就上个提督考虑考虑我朋友想问可以一直升挖iOS0-40吗可以可以我们公司有一个principle staff engineer零音的iOS的app有很多底层的东西是他写的然后他已经是我就我不知道他具体年龄是多少但是他和vp是一个级别的他和副总裁是一个级别的
或者说他汇报给服从材反正就是那一块他的影响力可以算是VP级别的但是他的直级可能是VP下一级对他就是LS做的就之前LS很多底层的东西包括data model什么的都是他写的所以外期我觉得可以我觉得是可以的只要你做的东西有深度能做的比较牛逼的一些项目我觉得没有问题了当然你不要一写UI一直写UI一直写UI那可能可能你的价值到后面就会缩水了
对吧你要积累一点自己的价值怎么看全站和移动端我觉得都可以吧就我们公司有那种一个需求所有端都是他一个人做的就安卓ios backhand就那个后端包括就整个一个项目全是他一个人做然后做了一个月就这种有然后也有就专专做一个移动端的就是都有都有我觉得吧
做的好做的好都没有问题都没有问题对吧嗯哇谢谢谢谢打扣啊谢谢打扣谢谢阿乐谢谢牛啊我喜欢考什么我喜欢我喜欢考DP我喜欢考一般我会选到简单这个能说吗这个是不是不能说啊就我会选到easy的体验easy的就很简单的那种然后给这个面试的人稍微有点这个底气好吧然后
然后我会考medium的dp然后其他我不太喜欢考那种代码量很长的我特别喜欢那种写出来的代码就没多少的那种对所以对就是我不喜欢那种答案很长的我就喜欢答案短的有些dp他就可以写的很短所以我喜欢考这个我刚35很快就要被猜了我觉得你不会啊你的影响力这么大
喵声什么时候来个直播喵声直播很多的你们不在意吧喵声前几天那个WWDC的活动还有呢LS团队管理有什么经验我是Engineer不好意思没有管理的经验好吧你们问题有点太多了我们赶紧下一个问题吧下个问题也是面试相关的就稍等稍等我这边先抽个奖吧好好感谢金主办吧然后先交回一个EF
对然后的话之前有接近一个小时吧然后就是又给我们分享了很多他的工作和生活经历吧然后我这边的话接下来中间差一轮抽奖然后就是之前呃说的那个中间有一个呃神秘抽奖吧对然后实际上大家应该都能猜到啊就是我们的这个
难道就达不到的DC那一餐啊写了有五年吧对吧然后review了一年好像我去年review的那一期最后没有上那位大家可以这个看一下就因为看文章肯定给看视频节省时间嘛对吧就github我github上没有什么有价值的东西不用求了我是当那个private的repo就是当一个仓库用的ok这个我们继续这个这个话题哈
就是算法这个事情好吧算法这事情大家比较关键一个是你千万不要懒好吧就我像我之前说的这个东西可能筛选不出你是一个优秀的工程师但能筛出来你是个懒的人就不要犯了还有就是有一个我觉得个人觉得这是一个tips嘛就是你三分钟想不出来你就赶紧去抄答案不是抄答案就看答案然后照着答案写对吧就我们其实是在刷算法是在学习
已有的算法不是在发明算法就是如果你没有见过这道题你不知道他该怎么做你在那暗想想一个小时去创造一个算法你这是浪费时间你应该学习现有的标准的揭发所以你三分钟想不到你就是抄答案就完了然后你把它混熟了就你把它背下来都行对你要保证你下次看到这套题你面色所面的这套题你要能做出来就可以了不要在那暗想不然很打击人的其实
有没有哪里能拨到我我有我的微博呀好像好像好像没有什么渠道可以发你可以先加群他们想加你的粉丝群你就先先加那个群吧先加大群吧就是剃杀龙的那个群然后后面我这边说一下就是那现在直播间右下角的这个二维码扫码加我们机器人然后就直接发送加群两个字然后机器人会直接拉你进这个
比如说幼的这样一个群其实就是他的粉丝群包括我们之后的话也不会过多的干预就是这个群管理对所以基本上就可以把它当作是幼的粉丝群来使用吧对然后至于幼会不会通过你的好幽浅球那就要平时多刷脸对ok 那个群是我的是吧我可以当全线狗是吧对的那个群是就是是你的然后你你现在应该也是管理员对哦好的好的
那转了那转了谢谢PK票上面还有礼物小心过去了谢谢发一下原神UID 100866567很好记可以加到我好不好原神我的好友有好多空栏然后我再看一下你们发的话话说又一开始和国外开会害怕英语口语吗那肯定害怕哪有人不害怕的对吧我之前还有很尴尬的就是
有一个IT我们叫EPE其实就是管电脑的部门他们有一些外包的在印度的一些team他会帮你的电脑比如说装一个插件这种事情然后他那天直接打电话给我你知道吗我当时入职还没有很久然后突然打电话给我我人都傻了当时但是我在干嘛了我好像在跑步不知道干嘛反正我在做运动然后
突然就一个电话国外的电话过来当时其实是有点懵的然后加上因为跨国那个电话他的信号也不太好语音质量也很差我完全不知道他在说什么然后最后只能让他发email给我因为真的没有办法沟通了对就这种小故事还是蛮多的就我我本身英语也不是特别好然后这种是尴尬的事情还蛮多的但其实你不要去怕就是你永远不做你就永远
进步不了对就是这样那个提拉拉这个技术在你是不是发出id了就类似啊我的微博类似的是这样的一个id谢谢艾乐谢谢艾乐谢谢小花花离开东英语口语怎么学找人说找人说你这个这话题太大了谢谢牛啊谢谢牛啊可以聊iOS一些方向吗你想问什么你可以问啊你姐有什么问题可以问但你不要问太大的比如说一个架构怎么搭那我花一天一夜跟你讲对不对
你可以问一下你想知道的就是答案不是特别长的那种我可以现在回答你好我们先下个问题吧问题还有好多啊现在专注哪块领域啊什么怎么构建技能树OK其实其实公司的话我主要还是在OS Swift这一块啊就工作技能树上比较常规然后我们用的一些框架
就比如说你们之前好奇的Combine和SwiftUI其实我们都现在都没有用我们有类似的思想是类似的 但是我们自言的就大厂嘛 喜欢造轮子嘛 但不是我们自言的是Global那边自言的但是他们自言其实做的蛮好的 就真的做的非常非常好有些还蛮重的 但是怎么说呢 挺好用的吧 用的就没有什么
有一些是比较个影的但我目前用的还是比较好的然后主要就是UI Kit写buttonbutton还是要写的然后其实你写完UI啊写完用功能它其实很少很少的一部分就是在一个feature里很少的一部分是开发是写UI之后的会有自动发测试写test写自动发测试的代码然后你再写可测试的代码的时候你会
你会你会改你之前写的那么就可能一个新手他刚开始写自动化测试你就会发现你自己以前写的代码都是是也好吧就是有些代码你写的不可测然后就会重构你之前的代码就慢慢的你就会越来越好然后会写task然后最后自动化测试然后还有文档啊沟通啊项目管理啊这些这些说实话可能
作为一些程序员他不是特别擅长但实际上这是我们的瓶颈也是特别需要提高的地方包括我我现在其实在文档沟通特别是沟通的项目管理上还是有瓶颈的
就是不够的地方所以这方面都是要去努力的东西就不要觉得你关系一个button它真的只会button那其实它写button只是10%好吧然后后面还有测试啊沟通啊文档啊项目管理啊包括check一些问题啊bug的收集啊然后线上的数据啊on call啊很多很多其实工程是一个很复杂的一个一个体系对然后我想说的一点就是大家
可以把多一点的精力放在这些软就文档沟通这些软实理上因为其实比如说你想升职你多会一两个框架或者多会一两门语言其实没有什么用的因为你升职卡的瓶颈根本就不在这所以与其你说多学一门语言你不真的不如在文档和沟通项目管理上多看看对我是这么觉得好你们刷了好多我看一下我也想学外语你自己学去
这个优一库颜值担当哈自己学去你在业余方面学那些业余方面我觉得就杂了flutter有在用吗flutter我也有在用但是我没有用在公司里我自己有一个sideproject是用的flutter web当时flutter web2.0就我上了一个类似于这个金融方面的基金方面的一个有点量化又没有很量化的一个
平台他的客户端上发头外写的最后是一个pwa可以装在手机上对我是在用的我觉得我觉得还行吧写着优化这个话题也太大结婚了吗没有单身音视频做过吗我还真做过音视频音频我做的比较少视频我做的比较多一点然后我做视频我我做过全景的视频还有做过多视频的融合就这一方面能做的也蛮多的但很多东西都已经
有现成的标准了吧比如说你视频UIGK嘛或者你自己从头写OpenGL渲染然后用那个什么video toolbox解码也可以但我觉得这方面更多的是你照着文档去录也没有什么你把它做得很好其实也没有很难做出什么大的这个东西吧除非你你能你能做到解码程你可以自己去垫一些解码
定一些格式啊你的定义的东西还能进标准这个东西是有价值的但我觉得你要想视频在视频上面做太多文章我我我现在暂时想不到好吧主播业余卷吗我还好吧我一阵一阵的我看心情的因为我因为外期业余时间相对还多一点我看心情的不爽就打游戏然后爽的时候就卷一卷是吧学一点东西
有RxSwift什么没有我之前RAC和RxSwift的时候大概看过我觉得这东西这个类型的东西这个类型的框架很多打同小异吧我觉得你用不用都行吧这东西入心性太强了我个人不是很喜欢OC还用吗OC底层框架还用的但我们不写了写的全部几乎都是Swift的就业务代码几乎Swift的我们还在把一些老的OC写成Swift
基本上swift把它切到swift上OC我覺得國內的很多公司還在用吧那是沒辦法對吧如果是新項目我真的建議不要再用OC它協調太麻煩而且還容易crash為什麼國內很多公司不寫自動化測試這個問題展開可以聊很多這個跟因為你知道嗎現在國外很多的APP它其實沒有
没有qa了就直接按着就工程师写完戴马直接上线了直接发板的有很多这个样子的因为我们就是我们认为啊就是我们这个共识力把这个人工qa替除到这个替除到这个附楼之外是整个工业流程水平上的一个进步对但是虽然我们可能会立刻一些bug到线上
但你把这个环节从整个pipeline提出去是一个进步我们是这么认为的很多公司没有这么做一个很多原因吧一个是文化上文化上可能就大家不舍得不想花这个力气啊这个原因很多了对吧等一下我这个弹幕滚飞了我要滚上去看见完了这个弹幕滚了找不着了我来聊一下吧
OKOK你向我找一下弹幕自动化测试的原因是因为可能你这周做的业务下下周就没了这是其中一个原因就真的因为就是很多业务就是发展的非常快吧就是如果你用就是比较正面的描述的话就是很多业务发展的比较快然后业务形态一直在变然后
呃可能长期会处于一个就是不是很稳定的一个状态吧所以就是其实你去做自动化测试的话在这种情况下其实是很难做的或者是根本就没有办法做的呃我觉得如果是要做的话可能一些比较基础的酷就比如说你可能底层的一些房内生啊或者是说
可能就比如说前面也聊到写button就不会真的去写button了但是你封装好的那个不管是button也好或者其他一些switch也好就是control之类的cool你肯定会去做一个unit test或者是一些其他的一些测试像这种的是是可以做的但是业务层的话对变动可能就太大了所以这种就没有办法做对其实是有办法做的就不愿意做罢了
大家国内厂他不愿意投成本之作一个是国内会写特斯的人他本来就少他可能你这个公司最最厉害的那几个老员工他也不会写特斯的就没有人去推这件事情我觉得对啊就关键不是说你没有人愿没有人去写的问题你不是说找不找不找得到人去写因为如果你公司招这样的人并且你给他说多少的年薪那么你只要招肯定会有人去写的现在就是
就公司根本就不會去做這樣一件事情所以也沒有人去做因為你如果說文化上大家就覺得QA就是應該有的對吧就應該人工來搞這個我覺得這個其實不能說好或者壞吧你只能說是每家公司或者是每個團隊有自己各自的根據實際情況最終得出的一個選擇或者是最終得出的一套方案有些公司他做的東西可能不是
不涉及具体的钱或者是就是金融或者是说信息方面的一些风险所以他觉得他立刻一些或者说甚至立刻很多Bug到现在去都没有什么关系反应啊随便玩我说就随便提我提我酷随便就黑我森文没有关系但相反的一些你比如说涉及到金融的一些业务或者说一些你可能就没有办法去承担这样的风险所以你各个团队得出来的结论或者方案都不一样我看这是一方面原因吧
对然后我刚才yef说的这个leak没有关系啊对了用我们的话说就是这个叫什么叫什么take intelligent risk就有一些risk我们是可以take的我们不需要就有一些小的bug我们是允许他到线上的他不会对我们的业务造成很大的影响谢谢小花花Lingado马上那么多离性消费啊老板就是是允许的就是take这个risk我们选择take这个risk然后
对就有些Buds我们不会保证说完全一点点Buds都没有比如说一个UI错位了我们认为这个分析是可控的然后是可以Leak到线上的然后不会有什么大的问题的我们会cover一些核心的Case就比如说一个功能这么正常主要的Case保证它的功能没有问题其实就可以了然后在这种情况下我们把QAT除整个环节
会使你的整个工程变得非常灵活就是你的master分支上任何一刻都是可以发版的就你不再有发版的这种这种这种日期了就你随时都可以拉出一个点就可以发版就我们追求的是这个但是你有人工QA就做不到的对所以我我们之前认为他是一个进步其实和最最最
最最关键的这个目标啊这个tunals这个方向其实是朝着任何master上随时发展这么一个目标去的我我我我我看一下你们弹幕可以聊聊现在用的一些技术嘛现在用的技术iOS啊swift然后一些内部的框架然后自动化测试我记得刚才有个问tester怎么学的tester我也不知道怎么学啊网上找一找那个苹果的官方文档看有没有这个有没有有没有这方面的内容
谢谢小花花啊离心消费好吧离心消费阿里尬兜阿里尬兜OK下一个问题还有问题吗同学们好下个问题是这个类似的就是目前有哪些这个零有目前哪些比较深入的前面的研究我我真不好说啊这个我可以给你们说一些我用到的吧就比如说我们客户端最近上graphql这个东西
国内使用的还相对比较少吧就是这个技术看起来我写下来的感觉就是又是一个看起来很浪漫其实有很多问题的像技术我个人意见还相对中立的GraphQL就是说你可以在Client写一些结构就你要哪个字段你就拿哪个字段就API它可能就不管你具体给你吐什么字段了就这么一个技术制
国外应该是有很多上了我记得instagram好几年前就上了因为我做他的爬虫的时候我之前我就发现他上了对graphql都死了但我们最近上了这个东西还有一些内部的框架了就基本上是纯swiftswiftUI只在这个widget词里未来我们肯定会继续推进的就我们追这个native的新技术还是有才是比较在意的就比较上心不会像国内这种
你出了个技术啊我们先等用户升级了等个五年我们再去考虑不会这样我们其实不会这样子也不算前一年吧确实已经晚了好几年了但是你要在一个现成的已有的工程上去上一个这么重的框架其实也是个挺庞大的挺庞大的工作量的大脑用Rust吗我写客户端我不用Rust我这边这个问题我我感觉我好像当时写的不是很通顺我以为你会感一下
好没事意思到了就行我们今天没有大概就是你都是闲聊对吧大家问题也很多谢谢牛啊谢谢谢谢杰瑞音音谢谢一念寻功能打哭啊牛啊谢谢还有蜡条谢谢trust deck谢谢哇你蜡条好多啊兄弟是因为蜡条不赖钱吗我也给你打一点我再看一下哈项目中一些不错的技术
我这我这必须得说了就我们我们其实在最近半年做了一个新的铃银app然后现在已经public ramp了但只有百分之十你们在iOS的在app store我不知道你们能不能你们应该是有一部分人能看到新的app的就如果是新版本的你下载来就会发现和以前长得完全不一样就我们从头开始写了整个我ef 辣条好多次我们从头写了整个app对然后
里面关键的技术比如说graphq啊这些话冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静冷静
好谢谢EF的这个几十个蜡条的谢谢这尼春有点意思的牛啊说你看这种送一毛送一毛钱礼物的至少也是钱对吧这个诚意还是到了谢谢你谢谢你这我都看不到弹幕了已经OK对我想想说到哪了跑偏了其实我觉得后端的一些大的就是一些前沿的前沿的技术比较多吧我关注的比较少啊科普端上能做的东西也少加一个吧
下一个也是相关的有没有使用阿恩会flutter对 我刚才说我们重写了一个新app再重写之前我们是有阿恩的有阿恩的但是只在一些少数的业务上做了然后好像效果不是特别好对我觉得跨平台方案它其实是有它的试用场景的权量上跨平台我觉得是不可能的
肯定是在一些这个适合他的场景或者是他的app比如说电商啊或者一些活动的页面啊我觉得可以上然后嗯对大概就是大概就是这样因为我知道国内有很多这个注重体验就不用跨平了跨平了对他们其实搞得挺卡的比如说我就不说这个gt app了我怕又物伤友军好吧就某些电商平台啊他就是卡
虽然他做了很多优化做了很多的分享技术能力很强但是他就是卡而且这个事情已经很多年了阿恩我记得从2015年还是什么时候已经很多很多年了都没有隔掉Native的命我觉得Native比较安全大家我个人觉得做Native是没有问题的
就不要听他们说NATV要死了像阿恩这么牛逼阿恩Flutter这么厉害All in阿恩我觉得这个见仁见智吧我觉得NATV是OK的而且你学iOS你肯定要学NATV的你要了解它的整个你说你不知道RUNLOOP是什么除非你写Flutter你写阿恩你也要知道RUNLOOP是什么不然你怎么depart呢你遇到一些crash你怎么办呢中规是要学NATV的所以做NATV没有问题嫌疑Flutter
我没说我可没说嫌疑啊我可没说哈不是我说的哈但我觉得flutter web用来做web对一些client的工程师挺友好的那你可能不懂web的一些事当然我会view啊我只是只是提一下就有些可能他只会只会一些native技术写flutter然后边把它打包成一个web挺整个过程
还是相对Smooth但是我不知道现在Bug少了没有我用的是flutter web2.0还是有挺多Bug的当时按实在看求推荐UI推荐UI组建库SwiftUI和UIKit我就推荐这里其他你们自己找吧SwiftUI你可以学起来但主要UIKit我个人给你觉得其他花里浮躁的人就不要去管了没有没有什么用
主播是断的时候我之前是去你主播嘛那我今天讲的断子已经算少了我考虑到大家都是技术的人不然我这玩的花都不行好了本次WDC中最兴奋的哪个特性因为我是做这个用户增长的所以我我这边观察到的就是最最最让我兴奋的特性啊其实就一个叫private access tokens就是可以绕过这个验证码的
因为我们做登陆注册遇到过太多被验证码卡住然后注册不了啊这个事情特别特别的烦然后这个东西这个技术可以绕过这个这个验证码所以我看到这个其实很兴奋的但是你想推这个东西还是很难因为整一套这个包括反作弊啊包括这个这个注册登陆的那些页面啊全部都在globo那边所以我们得推着他们做
对短期内感觉够呛但是我看到这个技术我很开心终于有大公司在主导解决这个问题了太太好了好吧太好了实在是谢谢艾亚谢谢艾勒艾勒大抗零一谢谢你啊谢谢成语新的打扣谢谢我若依的艾勒艾勒离开头项目里还会写tableview吗我们不直接写tableview我们有一些框架来搞这些东西客户端要oncom要的
客户端用户增长怎么做呢具体讲讲用户增长嘛我给你稍微讲几个大类吧一个就是拉薪一个是留存嘛对吧怎么样拉薪呢砸钱啊通过把这个用户的这个这个compan就是一些活动做得更好啊去掐饭是吧让一些app主推荐推荐这个我们的app然后来拉薪啊包括你去做一些学校的项目你到学校里去推广是吧都是
方法拉新然后流存怎么样流存呢就是提高你的这个产品价值嘛对吧你能体现什么价值比如说联姻你能找工作你能这个联系HR是吧你能看线新闻对吧那这些东西就是你品牌的价值就这两方面嘛对吧就总总的high level来看当然你细看其实有很多问题比如说你做了一个拉新的这个company然后拉了很多学生来注册但是呢这个学生因为都在一个学校里对吧他他
它网络出口是差不多的可能就是学校的内网然后我们的反作弊Antiabuse它可能就识别到你这个IP一天几万个几千个注册那肯定把你封了对吧那边这边一封那边就开始注册不了了然后我们一边砸着钱推广然后这个marketing的人来找我们注手不了了这个验证过不了了怎么办
那我们说那怎么办我们去找安提六子然后那边美国嘛又是在晚上那怎么办发邮件发邮件吹然后我们凌晨吹啊凌晨等他们上班了我们在一两点钟吹然后他们关然后有时候他们还不肯啊扯皮对吧那这个能做的事情是蛮多的我就大概给你们举个例子大概就是能做的东西很多啊但high level其实就这两个这两个方向原生调试要重新编译太慢怎么办你你
今天稍微調適你你要是你寫的代碼一次編頁一次運行就能過那不就沒有這個問題了嗎所以你可以提高自己的編碼的質量對吧你不要改一點點就讓一下改點就讓一下你可以寫的時候你想好你先把你的業務流程啊你要加東西啊你自己加完信心測不就完了嗎這麼簡單的問題有回答嗎應該是換ME嗎從自身這個
自身调这个找原因好吧从自身找原因然后对这个苹果官方其实可能也注意到这个问题了所以swiftUI不是出来一个preview吗对吧或者你用一些其他的工具去preview对其实我我我写过一些那个backhand的这个就是后端的一些工程啊就是我们我经常写后端就是
他们那个项目在本地run不起来的你就得写完你的代码你都一次都跑不了然后你把单面测试写了然后直接就上线了就是这样子的就是你本地有可能服务都起不来然后这就是为什么有些公司面试要求白板写代码他要求你的代码治疗有很多情况下就是你本地你写课不端可能还能跑起来你写有些服务他本地跑不起来或者
你就修一个bug然后你把他整个项目搞过来然后你配环境你可能都配不好然后有些情况你就草草的就改代马上然后把单册写完册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册册
我们这moke好像是自己写的吧我在github上没有搜到我们那个我们的那个项目可能是自己写的其实是什么ns那个什么什么network的一个proxy然后你就可以转发应该类似这种的就结上到网络库里面的我具体不太清楚我没有我看过那个代码但是我没有很仔细的看谢谢小花花谢谢安烈朵就是你可以我觉得可以看一下那个什么proxy的转发的或者你直接嵌入到这个你的
网络库里面啊你网络库你不发请求吗直接return吧对吧直接把那个请求的completion取出来直接see数字这个还是挺需要公司有这套生态的不然你一个人其实很难把这个test推出来好下一个啊到这了哈这期待Apple在哪些产品上有突破我觉得分两方面聊这个问题哈一个是我其实蛮期待Apple在硬件上发礼的
我最近感觉到一个很淡腾的地方就是苹果的GPU它训练深度学习的时候非常非常地慢 慢到根本没有办法用因为CALLML它其实是一个运行模型的一个空间它训练就非常的淡腾所以我没有办法在MARK上训练我觉得这是很多做深度学习的人的一个痛点就是它MARK上没有办法弄它被迫去搞一个舞帮处或者搞个Linux或者上云去搞这个
我真的希望Apple能让我们在Mac上可以训练神经网络这样的话对学习的成本会低很多对所以我很期待它的硬件上的提升包括MC的芯片都非常强当然我现在还没有拿到MC边的电脑我非常非常头疼我们公司一直不到货好头疼排队排了好久了希望能尽快拿到现在还在游英特尔的我的天呐然后
另一方面就是说开发者曾经要希望xcode能做得更好一点xcode不要再crash了不要再发热了我的天呐这真的是我觉得困扰大多数开发者都是xcode工具链的问题他在那个app store评分其实很低嘛对吧然后我看下一个人写一个项目怎么提升自己你一个人写你说你只是side project还是公司项目就你自己的项目还是公司项目如果是公司项目
你其实很难对很难如果你是个人项目的话你就写就完了我这里推荐其实我我会swift的服务端就我之前服务端是用swift写的就很早很早的可能从16年开始就我不推荐大家就用swift再去学swift的服务端但是如果你
只会LS然后你想写些服务端我觉得SWIFT的可能服务端是好上手的相对好上手的一个地方然后你就可以啊你写吧把整个项目写下来嘛对吧然后上线吧部署到自己服务器上然后那啥下然后总结一下对吧有哪些痛点然后维护维护时间久了就会有经验了就写就完了海外工序可以出海可以吗什么意思什么意思
没看懂自己补贴买那不存在的不是我们自己的电脑是进不了公司的内网的所以你自己的电脑没有用的你进不了公司内网什么都干不了带完也拉不下来工具链也装不了今天teams挂了对今天teams挂了但我们早上时候Hands我们在zoom开我们改到zoom开了今天早上有个全员大会后面临时改到zoomteams确实是挂了今天刚到手的Max Studio真香哇你真好羡慕能不能给我
公司项目你想一个人从头你是只跨端还是不跨端如果是公司项目你的manager让你做你就做呗有什么不懂的问他他不懂的让他找人比如说两个东西解决不了让他找人去manager的职责不就是给你找吗找资源吗对吧inter风扇在开飞机对我们的笔记本还是i9的那个特别特别热现在我都丢一边了我们还有一台这个大的iMac Pro我现在都用那一台笔记本实在是没有办法用太卡了
想了解一下UI适配UI适配是内部的方案我不好说啊这我们内部有个框架它都是自动处理的我能说的就是其实还是out to the out就是UIC的out to the out然后加上这个accessibility和这个这个跨国国际化的那个localization的这个就英文和中文嘛双语嘛对吧就还是基本的一些底层还是基本的没有
其他的就不像之前我记得有个嘉宾分享他们是用我们之腰化我没有没有那样的不推荐所有的服务端是为啥因为没有公司用了学的没有用了对吧我其实已经掉入了这个深坑了因为我已经写了好多年了我有很多的代码积累所以我现在想要写一个带后端的东西我还是会用我的框架因为我自己已经写了一套框架了所以我自己用起来一个是很熟一个是
我能保证他是稳定的因为线上用了好多年了我能保证他是stable的他不会有一些我应该遇到的问题我那么多年应该都已经遇到了对吧所以我属于误入企图大家如果要学的话还是去学java吧真的self的服装用什么cool perfect我不推荐用vapor因为我当年我有一次想把它签到vapor我后来发现
vapor连http的range都不支持就是你比如说在视频里放了个mp4的视频那个mp4视频它其实是一段一段持的对吧当时的vapor是不支持range自断的因为说这个视频你根本放不了然后我当时很生气因为我做了挺多事情了已经做了很多工作之后发现它这么这么基本的一个一个这个这个http里的标准都没有实现我也很生气当然现在好像已经有了有人修了
我我当时应该是18年的时候还是没有修我就特别神奇然后perfect因为他不是一个入侵性的框架所以你可以渐进式的用它对吧比如说你接个mysuckle你就用perfectmysuckle你其他的整个框架你是不用动的就不像那个vapor你要用他的这个async的整个async的架构这个入侵性太强了我没有snapkit提一个屁啊那我们
急着做自己的side project哪有空帮你修Bug这最基本的HTTP的标准都没有实现这就该拿上来用吗我就不太懂那些推荐vipers之前怎么解决的range用的地方还是蛮多的吧我不懂好那我们下个问题吧我们还有好几个问题怎么看客户端前途还有后端算法港是不是更香我觉得这个看公司文化真的因为
在不同的公司不一样啊就比如说之前百度吧他其实是重服务端的然后有的公司他是重客户端的比如说零音我觉得有点重客户端的因为我们之前零音最早只有一个web嘛对吧后来我们做了mobile后来我们有有一个战略就是mobile优先啊就是我们就尽量的能把mobile做好所以零音感觉有点重客户端的这其实看公司然后
其实前端也挺难的客户端也挺难的但他不太好吹牛就是你写文档你非常难写非常难吹就大项目非常难难去有那种很大的很好吹牛的项目所以后端确实要相一点算法的话我觉得现在的这个供需的比例不太ok就是供应有点太多了
对然后算法我估计转的转的飞起我们做客户团的你想去转算法我觉得能度很大我们公司都在放弃客户团了那确实有的公司他可能觉得前端能能cover的那就只要前端就好了对吧所以这真的是看那个公司的好其次的我还想说一个点就是其实每个人他都有每个人的特质就是你有你喜欢的东西是吧
你可能你不能觉得后端比如说算法课后端工资高一点你就去追求然后你写得很痛苦这个我觉得没有必要啊就是你要平衡好你你的这个兴趣啊特长啊然后和这个发展的这个关系对吧然后还是还是那句话吧就是不要抹杀你作为人的那个部分你是一个人不是一个赚钱的工质你如果喜欢客户段你就做客户段吧
不要硬转好不好不要硬转就大家有的时候把自己逼得非常狠啊非常辛苦啊说我是我个人是不推荐的就不崇尚的这种这种行为前端客户端占比多少啊我们这边没有什么典型性啊因为我们很多还是就之前用的是某web用的是global的就0.cn是最近才慢慢搞起来的所以我们没有什么典型性
你要不问一下其他小伙伴吗看有没有小伙伴这个回答的谢谢EF的100个牛啊现在找不到LS开发怎么办其实有的吧岗位还是有的吧现在问题可能是新人比较少了所以资深的人比较多就是市面上有的吧我觉得我印象中还是有的谢谢EF好吧破费了破费了我更喜欢钱
个人选择好吧可是这个大家见人见识自己选择价格就是毕业潮啊哎时代的一里杀落在每个人身上都是一座山所以这个问题你说怎么看呢首先你找工作的时候你尽量找合规的公司啊就是你找工作尽量找正规一点的靠谱的当然我这个话说的有点站着说话不要疼毕竟大多数人可能大厂进不去然后只能投一些小厂
但这个没有办法好吧没有办法然后尽量吧只能说尽量找一些靠谱的稍微大一点的公司然后在公司你尽量吩咐一些自己的精力吧就是能做多做错多做什么多学什么的自己看着办好吧自己看着办尽量让你的精力吩咐一点然后以至于你万一真的被踩了你不至于说你找工作的时候能比比其他人有点优势啊就比如说小公司
你有的时候可以承担很多事情的对吧那这些都会成为你简历的一部分经历的一部分然后你接下来找工作你肯定会比其他人有优势然后我还想说的一点就是有的时候努力是没有用的就是努力真的有的时候没有用的就是这个时代的浪潮拍上来的时候你个人的努力真的没有用
就其实互联网现在不是最惨的行业就像娱乐行业啊什么餐饮行业啊那真的是灭顶之灾好吧这个互联网其实已经算还行了这是我以为你下一我以为你下一句要接小镇做提家了没有没有没有小镇做提家我很欣赏我特别欣赏陈其豪的人因为我我其实小时候成绩不好对我特别这个欣赏那个爱爱学习和那个陈其豪的人嗯嗯
我未来有什么职业规划后面应该有这个问题吧我记得有这个规划说起来有点太那个太官方或者太正式了不是特别好说我们谈到那个问题的时候再讲吧好吧35k以上的岗位除了字节其他很少的有的就是有的比如说外企有很多啊当然外企很多缩招了但还是有在招的我今天被TikTok三个人拼了吧应该是三个HR我都麻了
就是你可以看一些外企啊就是消息好像也不太好但tiktok招的挺多的当然这个可能有点卷啊那边可能有点卷你们自己订多好吧有还是有的然后下个问题是nft别比这外不三啊这个我其实买了数字货币但我没有买nft啊
就我从我个人一下为个人见解不是正确答案大家听听就好就从技术层面讲我从来都不觉得七块量以后会有什么大型的应用出来就不可能的但是我还是买了因为它至少有你说它有价值一个它是限量的一个是它有一定的社交价值对吧你说为什么一个爱马士的包卖好几万真的是那个包值那么好几万吗它不是的它可能有一定的社交价值
你可以跟有些人有话题聊对吧这个是他价值一部分但但从技术层面来说我是不幸的好吧然后去中心化这个是不可能的就是去中心化这个东西提了很多了就不管是从技术上还是从这个政策上在现在这个地球上不可能的对除非你往线我往线给你拔了你的去中心化我跟DNS服务器给你拔了对吧我说美国哎呦大家都别上网了我把跟DNS服务器给你断了
能让你去中心化是吧你没有办法的所以我觉得在地球上很难做到这个东西就算你是PT啊你知道以前叫BT就是BT下载那种东西啊它其实是有Tracker的是有个Tracker服务器的它是中心化的对吧它肯定有些技术比那些中心化下载的稍微不中心化一点但你想掐掉这个网络其实有办法的就像现在PT叫PersonalTracker它都是有PersonalTracker服务器的你玩的东西断了就下载不了了
所以我是这么觉得这个ef应该有更多的看法吧ef可以发表一下你是指我亏钱的经历吗你已经亏钱了吗我已经亏了不少钱了ok ok那你怎么看呢对于这个这些技术我觉得这个东西其实你很难去首先我觉得就是你刚才就是那些分析我都觉得是
就是相当于说有有一定的依据吧对吧就至少听起来也是很合理的对但是其实我们可能很难用现在的视角去预测一个十几年或者是几十年以后的一个状况所以我可能不会去下一个论断说耳提也好微博山也好或者是元宇宙也好他们纯粹是吵概念就是荷兰玉京香
或者是说他们在多久的之后会有真的一个落地比如说真的可能过了30年50年然后美国人说我要把他跟服气然后大家说我们有web3那也说不定也能成为现实对吧所以我觉得这个东西很难就是你说他有没有一个光明的未来或者怎么样但是其实我觉得作为
就是我们因为很多包括很多听众码包括我们都是成选都做拍发的但如果他这个浪潮能够持续一段时间的话对我们来说是有一定积极的意义的比如说前面有同学问到说在是不是除了BAT或者是说头部的这些大厂就没有35k以上的职位了在Web3就有很多如果你现在能够非常熟练的用Solidity去写Web3的合约去写一些EBM建筑链的合约
那么你现在掌工都非常的简单非常的轻松就是这是当前的实话但是这不构成任何的职业发展或者是投资建议对就是所有的东西都要那个do your research对是这样我觉得业夫说的挺好的所以你信和不信其实在现在没有办法下定乱你可以买一点对吧像我就买了一点币然后现在亏了很多
但我从打心底是不幸的但是我还是买了我用钱投了一点票对所以对于这种拿不准的东西我个人现在可能变得愿意take a little risk就是冒一点行稍微买一点对吧万一呢对吧万一我刚才这个话可能得罪了很多搞web3和ft的同学个人见解好吧个人见解免责声明不要杠我
一F亏钱了我是不信的有人不信啊不论你看最近的那个1000H或者是BTC价格高峰的时候6万跌到现在2万17万8我不敢打开我的账户1000H去高点的时候60008还是多少反正到现在之前低点800吧都已经超跌这么多了天呐
都不敢动我好吗你就根本就不知道接下来应该是做什么反正现在就已经躺平了现在反正已经不敢打开我的账户了对呀那那那句话怎么这么这么亮丽而行亮丽而行亮丽而行对吧就是就是什么就是牛牛牛是牛是什么牛是什么吃烧烤什么什么是
熊是在家打游戏什么摔七八糟的反正就是感觉他们必签这种图一套一套的吧对反正就是我觉得就是分开看嘛如果是你是把它当做投资那么你要了解他投资的风险如果是你是把它当做一个A就是趁他的这样一个发展是有一些可以对自己的生活或者是说工作是有一定的助力的所以你可以说OK我你
觉得它后面不会成但是至少它这波浪潮在的话你至少接下来的五年可能有点长那三年至少还是有希望的那如果说你现在可能本身就是一个觉得移动端不景气或者说就是就是整天就是觉得说ls没人要了然后包括自己也确实就这么想那你其实可以调试去转移一下就是这种就是所谓的区块链开发然后或者是说
你不想转线合约的你觉得它太虚了你可以转前端呀因为其实现在所谓的web3开发也就是有一个森威端有一个那个sony的铁的线上的一个合约链上的一合约外加一套前端嘛就基本上就不会有人想到做App的做App的话这条链路就太长了所以说那你iOS你其实是可以转前端的包括前面也聊了很多flutterflutter可以做flutter伪吧对吧
你如果不做flashweb,那你就直接转gms,gms的话你后端路级gms,前端用gms去写一些就是页面,然后gms一把说也可以啊,你都可以趁这个机会去做嘛,然后的话其实反正据我了解到23行业现在开的薪资,相对于我们现在我们现在在在做和bub2的比较落后的行业,他的薪资是非常夸张的,大概这个样子。
感谢业务分享的这个监督安岗位我是接触的比较少因为从来没有往那方面转行想过这个事情你能不能推荐一下这个搞一下内推啊让大家找工作容易点大家找工作容易点我内推是没有用的得让整个经济形式变好好吧这个我是做不到的内推光内推有什么用啊你们得这个候选人得努力啊对吧
还有就是经济形势啊能让公司过得更好目前前端在学lbs啊你现在就属于这49年加入国军了吧欢迎欢迎欢迎好不容易有新鲜学业你干啥呀你走开你在你在你就有点像骗萌新入坑的时候原神这个有点不干我没骗人家自己在学好吗我没有骗
欢迎好吧欢迎热烈欢迎加入ls行呀没事你两个都会的话找工作没有不会局限的对吧挺好的挺好的学什么都是可以的哦我记得上面还有个问题啊说人生转折啊我人生转折高考三次换工作对吧三个工作嘛全部都是转折所以工作高考和工作基本上就是这样每个转折都有巨大的意义就
都严重影响了后来的发展路径和生活在哪个城市乃至各种各样方方面面这个说来话长了中长期职业规划这个你从官方上来讲啊无非两条路啊一条叫individual contributor就是IC啊就是engineer就是一直一直一直写写代码或者做技术一条就是manager对吧就是做管理就是官方上就是这两条路但是
我觉得这个不重要就重要的是你在你现在团队里面能不能找到一些感兴趣的业务然后能让你呆下去的就是你能在这个世界不一定是公司的整个世界你在地球上能找到一块你真的很想去做的东西然后能做下去然后等到你是要决定转i转manager或者继续做ic的时候你肯定就会答案了这个问题其实在我这我其实不太看重
我不太想就是现在来做这个选择这肯定是到时候自然自然而然的就选出来了不过我现在让我回答我肯定喜欢IC对吧因为我这人比较怕麻烦我很害怕和人打交道虽然我现在因为搞了很久直播我现在已经有点射牛了就是画有已经有点多了但是我这人还是比较怕麻烦的目前IOS在学校外卖怎么样能多送几单
你可以在手机上写个app然后帮你这个规划一下路线最后利用比如说高的地图的sdk啊你把它弄进来然后自己规划路径当时转折的时候有做什么选择吗啊那肯定有啊你高考你不是选择吗肯定做选择啊你跳槽肯定做选择啊对吧那我觉得我其实比较重要的这个选择选的是对的一个是在
在我来北京之前就我第一份工作在中科院嘛对吧后来我去找了杭州的工作杭州的两份工作全部都没有药物后来我就面了百度就是北京的然后决定来北京那是我很重要的一个转折第二个转折就是我在19年的时候选择来外期就到Lincoln这个选择以至于现在其实很多国内的大厂它全部都股价腰转或者膝盖转然后
虽然现在因为我们领英发的是微软的股票嘛我们是微软的全资子公司微软的股票其实虽然现在有点低但是相对那些个中概股已经好了非常非常多了所以我觉得几些跳槽都都蛮关键的然后选的目前来看都还蛮不错的当然你说有没有可能选留在杭州更好呢其实有可能为什么呢假设你当时留在杭州了那万一现在可能
好像没有什么可能杭州只有阿里巴巴好吧因为目前看其实选的还可以这就是我但你要回过头来说我当时凭什么这么选其实我也想不到后面会发生什么事情就是都是命好吧都是运气我现在真的归咎于运气就是你当时根本就没有想这么多的我跳槽的时候我从来不会知道后面有疫情然后直接股价斩到死亡了这个绝对不可能在19年年初的时候预料到的
对所以一切都是命吧真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真真
所以中掌机直接规划我觉得水道 桥手自然值吧重要的是你在这个地球上能不能找到你感兴趣的业务有没有做LVM没有有没有做个底层技术有一些项目涉及一些底层技术吧但这个就不方便展开了你问的太难回答了你感觉像在面试我好吧好OK 下一个就是怎样快速上手一门没有接触过的技术比如说我最近在学生读学习这个很有意思
我觉得首先首先你要确定你满不满足你要学到这个东西的前置条件比如说你学深度学习首先你得学过高速和线性带数不然你没有办法看懂课的数学原理当然你说我不懂也没关系现在有很多现成的网络直接扔进去训练其实也可以但是你要做到能够找工作的程度你词码
现代和高速是要取过的然后概率稍微懂一点对吧然后接下来就是你首先你确定这个东西你是能学的ok 你满足他的条件然后你要做的这个东西你得有一定的domain knowledge什么叫domain knowledge就是你比如说你做计算机视觉你要识别一个东西现在当然深度学习你可以不懂视觉但以前我们做那个
机器学习的时候你要知道视觉的相关的一些知识比如说它识别图片是怎么识别的它其实识别一些特征啊识别一些文理那特征是怎么提取的呢它是有一些比如说OpenCV里面有些函数对吧边缘检测的什么safe to self什么这些乱七八糟的函数你要有这个domain的knowledge然后你就可以去学了接下来就是你找资料就行了找资料很多对吧咱们B站很多然后唯一要那个你要在意的就是你要找值得你相信的
材料就有一些它是割韭菜的客人就不要去管了就比如说有一些专门就是卖客的那种卖就是为了卖客的那种视频我我建议就是少看然后你去找一些大佬的或者非常非常值得信任的这个这些资料就比如说iOS啊我iOS就怎么学的我觉得是CS193P啊就是那个items u上斯坦福的那个呃CS193PiOS编程的就是斯坦福的客
这个是值得相信的我是按照这个学的我积极学习是怎么学的我不知道大家知不知道B站上有个好几十万粉丝的一个亚马逊的工程师叫李慕他出了一本叫D2L就有一本什么动手深度学习他出了这本课还出了这本书他在B站上上传了这个课他这个课讲得非常ok然后这就是值得相信的学习资料然后你就去跟着做就完了
对吧最后最后呢你要找个东西做一下就是像当于我们现在已经有个锤子了你现在要找个钉子去敲一下就做个东西用对吧比如说你学iOS那iOS你得写个app出来对吧比如说最简单我们就写个计算器你把计算器给写出来计算器很简单但它里面有很多数据结构数据结构和算法的一些东西比如说怎么翻转一个站啊变成一个对列对吧对这种东西大家应该学算法都知道就这个东西你最后实践了
然后就ok了然后你就去看一些岗位的这个面试要求对吧你看这个岗位你要什么东西你插什么东西然后去学学去备一备然后找工作ok大概就这个流程好大概就能至少我这边iOS是正玩个流程我当时学那个iOS的时候就是cs193p学完之后其实找不到工作就是因为我没有去备那些那个八古文啊就是我面试的一些知识点
那后来其实你我大概就花了半年的时间看一看书背背就ok了就很简单这个东西没有没有太高的门槛对但前提啊最重要的就是你得知道这个东西你是能学的能做的就不要说你你那个呃没有学过现行代数你要去做深度学词你这个后面会做不下去的对然后你现在再去看那些课你可能会睡着了你可能要付出超过这个普通的这个常人的这个努力
概率论不能只懂一点要懂很多这个因为我深度学习懂的我没有这个做过相关的工作所以我不知道这个要概率论要懂到什么程度一般理工课的大学都会学这个概率论所以我感觉大家应该后多后少懂一点斯塔夫那个课还挺不错的我觉得就是我觉得他没有教那个自动化测试有点可惜宇宙镜头进行视野编制现在这个公务员都降薪了对吧视野编制
也不是很穩的外企是不是版本答案这个不好说世界边这都不一定是版本答案公务员都不一定是版本答案你们记得90年代那个下岗潮吗当时是国企大批的下岗你们知道吗可能加这个观众里有些人爸妈或者这个亲戚经历过这个事情的当时以为可能国企穩得一批后面发生什么了对吧记得对吧
所以說這個公務員和國企他可能說不好的我們這個微軟已經40年了微軟創立已經40年了你覺得微軟它倒有可能嗎有你覺得公務員很穩嗎公務員那之前現在不就降薪了嗎之前國企還下過港沒有什麼是100%穩的沒有什麼是100%的都減公務員幾年後也不行了大概我就這個意思
我问下一个就是有什么值得推荐的学习资料对这就是我刚才说的一个就是itunes u上cs193p啊就是西坦福的ls的课要学ls可以看这个他讲的非常的系统但是可能不适于就不适用于国内找工作公务员绝对比微软稳itunes in收至少我们没有降薪哦甚至我们还涨薪哦明天对吧第一个是itunes u的cs193p这个学ls的可以去学那个
但是你要找工作你得另外看书然后B站我们B站上很多知识区的视频比如说礼幕的集体学习对吧这我也是我推荐的然后当然还有些其他领域比如说你感兴趣的天文啊地理啊国际政治啊科学啊什么量子力学啊相对论啊全部都有挺多UP主做的就直接在B站搜就可以了我挺推荐的还有就是半佛啊讲讲人生也挺有意思就现在的学习资料已经大量大量溢出了就B站就能找到很多
只要是学就可以了我估计cs加主3p当年只有爱冲慈悠后面上了网易公开课现在我估计比战也有然后跟弹幕这一些同学一起学就挺有意思的深圳好像没有什么还要是外资看我这我不确定深圳有那个啥吧有有消息吧消息有深圳的吧我记得对应该会有什么推荐的学习资料吗可以发表一下
WDCR内餐大家过去买那个书没有中奖同学快去买WDCR的这个内餐就这个WDCR现在的赛选很多的非常多好几十个100多200多个吧你要全部看视频是不现实的再给大家去看书吧就大家总结好的书看起来会比那个视频快10倍吧对吧5分钟看完和你花半小时就没有10倍6倍吧6倍吧
蕭皮对蕭皮有深圳的哦snapchat对snapchat今年有没有开新客我不知道我现在没看了每年都买推广是我们的赞助商所以你们可以多买点多买点买10本送朋友有没有提效的开发工具啊这个我推荐首先是这个项目就沟通类型的google doc肯定就现在国内可以用腾讯文档就是合作类文档是一个
之前我记得有那个谁也说过这个事情就是在线文档是一个革命性的产品比如说你在给别人写一个文档你不用改一版发一个改版发一个然后最终版最终版最最终版最最最终版不像这样子的你就发一个google到来链接你有什么改的你就直接上面改就完了对就是一个革命性的东西大家真的尽量要去用然后还有就是我推荐一个git的GUI工具把一个
叫Folk 啊就叉子FORK这个是之前标准推荐的一个Gate的GUI工具啊大家可以去如果需要的话可以用当然以前那个Tower也可以啊就是他TOW一下Tower也可以接下来就是啊项目管理的我推荐Jira 但我不知道这个国内我就估计让国内公司用不太现实我就不说了这个应该是要买的然后还有StackStack真的因为Stack他的聊天可以分Strat的就是一个单个回复
就是你单独回复活台消息会多出一条楼就这个功能特别特别需要国内是不是飞出什么的也会有我尽量建议用这种可以楼中楼的不然你的整条这个大群的聊天制度会非常非常乱然后最后就是常用的快捷键大家去记一下比如说Command加B就是Build的Command加R就是Round还有就一些常用的Xcode的快捷键大家
尽量去背一背因为快捷键真的比你鼠标点快很多就操作起来会丝滑我大概就推荐这几个吧超尔定面值太贵了啊foc是免费的啊直接用foc吧我的直播用什么工具啊你指的是我直播间还是人偶啊还是其他东西啊我这里设计了七八个工具啊这都是我直播半年多攒下来的一些工具这个说起来有点复杂实际Strike语音总段我没有遇到过会不会是网络的问题
飞书有OK飞书有那挺好的就尽量用楼中楼的这种这点好看哦这个就是你后面说的这个conformancesconformance它就是weekly了对吧就weekly我觉得还是不太好用weekly还不如google doc可能所以我建议大家用google doc这种温导这个conformance可能对那些啊非engineer的人会比较比较有帮助一点就是他们可能喜欢在这个这个这个这个就鼠标点对吧
就我们可能工程师更喜欢国道和这种比较清爽一点人偶人偶是那个啥呀 PR PR LIVE呀这个你如果看训练主播你挺会知道的不看的话其实你也没有必要知道这是一个收费的在steam上可以下载的可以买的一个软件怎么安排个人的工作生活时间因为大部分是我房后嘛所以就在家呆着在家呆着对吧
然后现在北京是72小时核酸了就其实还是挺麻烦的就所以就尽量就不出门了然后工作吧嗯分情况有的时候啊就是直接就是早上起来可能10点半或者10点了然后做点东西就吃直接当一餐不让吃就就不吃早饭直接早饭和中饭合成一餐吃完11点多或者12点开始工作一直到晚上5点多就是一口气把工作干完
然后下班或者如果要去公司的话一般就10点半多到然后5点多走吧因为我在公司不吃晚饭的所以就5点5点多走因为你再晚走可能就堵车了或者地铁紧不进去了所以就早点走然后晚上如果有事的话在家再干活反正电脑在家有我们我现在手上好几台电脑家里放了一台晚上的话就要么打打游戏要么学学东西最近在学生都学习嘛就练练单嘛对吧
只要200块什么只要200块你说是那个git的工具吗谢谢粉丝登牌哦it walk声明羡慕啊没什么好羡慕的因为我们比较这个比较这个结果导向嘛其实你干完活就可以了什么时候干其实并不注意所以有的同事可能头一天晚上很晚所以他第二天中午才来或者下午才来我们之前有同事两三点两点多才到公司的然后
但是他晚上可能稍微晚一点反正活干完就行了没有那么多限制Folk买licenseOK但Folk是免费的你可以一直不买的就是他那个窗口是可以关掉的谢谢粉丝能排我们的一卷老板不走都不走那这个就是公司文化了对吧有没有出过计划对我分享刚开头的时候就说其实之前是有的对吧之前是有的后来
我是19年入职后来20年就疫情了嘛其实入职之后一年都不到就马上疫情了然后后来还打仗对吧打仗然后经济衰退就业环境差然后这一切就我现在其实没有计划了外面太危险了而且回国机票太贵了出去了怎么也得回来也得好几万就顶不住啊家里有没有矿
但我们公司其实是有相关的计划就是相关的政策的是可以transfer的那是现在个人原因吧如果有路播嘛应该是有的用它很久了支持一下可以可以这个就是开发者们最喜欢的用户现在找不到工作觉得应该降薪找小公司吗看人吧你如果现在有经济压力那肯定尽快找到公司啊对吧或者对看你缺不缺钱嘛你要不差钱就在家躺着
等整個這個經濟衰退過了差錢你肯定是比如說你有房貸或者很重的車貸房貸肯定是盡快恢復收入嘛對吧這個看個人啦這個很難說然後遊戲中在本遊戲在生活中是角色這個問題有的同學覺得牢一結合就是遊戲就是意嘛辦公室牢嘛但其實在我眼裡遊戲絕對不是意啊就是遊戲嘛作為一個這個
第七艺术啊第九艺术啊第七艺术啊反正他是他有这么一个这个定义啊就是他会通过他的故事啊世界观啊性格啊人物性格啊会一定程度的影响你的这个行为和思考的方式的所以游戏对我其实像一部电影或者一本书你可以把它当成是一但是你去看的时候或者你去玩的时候一定是这个首脑变用啊对不是五脑的那种对不像刷短视频啊
就游戏绝对是一种特殊的这个特殊的事情这不亚于学习一门艺术其实学习一门技术这其实我在玩游戏的状态跟我在学一门技术的时候是差不多的就是比较投入然后去感受那个游戏的那些东西的我不知道大家对游戏是什么什么什么一个看法我我个人是尽量减少那种重复的游戏的就比如说当然我没有资格说这个话好像现在原神
天天上去打工就是游戏打工仔你们知道吗就是有一部分人他就在游戏里打工啊天天上去干某些特定的事不干完就不睡觉就我觉得这个是没有什么太大的必要尽量减少吧尽量减少可能玩一个吧就比如说天天要干的就玩一个是吧其他时间去玩些有有真正内涵的东西就比如说比如说啊我不知道举这些例子大家有没有把握过就比如说那个
我这叫什么就我的战争吧有点像就他描绘的是战争之后的废土然后你作为里面的人你要活下去是吧然后你会遇到不同的流浪汉你又要收留他们然后你去别临之家抢东西但是你要饿死了然后那你是抢还是不抢你是杀还是不杀这些都是比较考验人性的一些东西我以为你要推荐深圳来呦
下班之后继续上班这期十二层打算什么时候打满不打了我打不过十二层不行打不过妙审居然还在我以为你已经jump了我打不过十二层好吧这几期他总是针对那个冰系的输出我打不动昨天刚完花园大标客啊不是大标客我之前对就是像这种有一个完整的世界观我是特别喜欢的
这些粉丝登牌哦ok 接下来最后一个问题了吧怎么想到这个做主播的啊然后相关的技能怎么学其实我做主播已经转身了三次了好吧就之前瞎拍都算了就好好做视频的最早应该是18年然后后面转身了好几次了啊就突然想搞这个了我先开一个号搞这个然后你说这个视频怎么
怎么怎么学的话其实其实就是学那些软件啊对吧你简视频是用什么我是用Final Cut Pro或者iMovie你可以用A1或者用什么大分歧啊这种就我来玩你选一个你喜欢的你就学他怎么用然后就行了你可以从简单的开始做是吧从关键帧从配乐然后开始然后你可以尝试一下精简啊然后做一些各种各样的花火对吧然后
网上其实很多教程的这个你学就完了这没有什么难度的然后我觉得比较重要的一点是你要学习整个行业是怎么转的怎么运行的比如说B站你发了一个视频只有50播放那怎么办呢你就得观察啊观察比如说有一些差不多的主播比如说他也就100个粉丝哎我也100个粉丝为什么他呢一两千你就观察他他是不是好好做分面了好好写标题了这两个特别特别重要就是
B站是根据什么来分配这个流量的这个你是可以去观察可以去学的怎么样的视频能拿到更多的流量然后这个你经过可能投了10个视频吧你怎么也得摸索出来了对吧你投了10个视频可能有的两有一两千有的50但其实就可以摸索出来他这个共有没有共同的特点啊之后呢其实持续的去做就完了持续的迭代嘛对吧主播B站叫什么
我不是很打算給我現在這個賬號引流因為我不太直播了現在 對然後然後這個事情其實有一個困擾廣大這個創作者一個很大的問題就是這件事情投入產出比時代太不成比例了很多人努力了好多好多年做了1000多個視頻沒有任何收穫的非常非常多假如你不是很享受這件事情的話就是止損好吧 止損然後
有的人可能啊我不知道大家有没有看见过有一些什么比如说开会去主播他就一个手机对着脸在那讲话就火了对吧你可能很不服气啊为什么呢这个他这样子就火了你你就不火呢对吧这个没有什么为什么呢这个事情就是投入成熟比很差的所以哎这个讲起来有点有点伤感其实总之你要去做这件事情你决定人就去做就完了
然后叠在你的策略好吧根据反馈叠在你的策略比如说你发了某些视频反响特别好你就往那方向发可能你做了一个差不多的没有火你要想为什么是不是标题取得不好分面做的不好那种节奏不好内容太长了或者内容太短了或者那种质量画面质量不好对吧可以自己去叠戴差不多就是这些好了这边我们的问题就问完了最后的Q&A了
要聊了很久啊这聊了有两个小时吧这是海情主要是今天下午还有场直播直播的我有点口干瘦到大家还有什么问题吗可以可以问哦嗯本来不是本是不是本来的二十点半就不一定吧砸潭的形式比较宽松吧你们问题问得多的话我就这个慢点讲如果如果没有什么问题我们就讲比较快就结束了
没有什么固定时间我我之前做砸弹都是很随便的就是甚至没有准备任何问题上来直接和观众聊天的对就关关心主主播B站的账号是你的可以直接加群加群就可以跟主播直接交流对然后因为我们这边是以一个做和做然后技术直播的方式来做的所以我们这边的话还是就是会
把相关的这些交流放在我们这边拉的一个交流群里面不然的话可能某些嘉宾会不是很方便吧因为不是所有人都愿意公开自己的联系方式或者怎么样所以我们还是希望把这个流程给规范化感谢EF这个他们有人说机器人没理诶
那可能是掉线我把它重新跟上处理一下对然后这个零件工资差别多大这个首先工资每个人都不一样其次工资有很大一部分是股票股票每个人拿的价格也不一样是吧微软这几年早了好几倍所以你不同时间入职的人工资差别可以差数倍接下来美国发的是美金啊你这中国发的人民必养这肯定差了
得挺多所以这个不好说的因人而异对通常来说可能美国那边new grad就刚毕业的这个这个效率招生可能当年我当年可能15万美金吧就是我毕业附近的时候15万美金的现金加上股票股票因为翻了四倍了你就很不好算对反正一两百两三百万从有的吧就放到现在的话值得算人民币这个因人而异吧这个不好不好算
算stuff有多难哇太难了我升不上去好吧这个就像我刚才说的你得找到这个找到这个产品中有价值的点之作啊这个事情是最难的希望我留个flag在这里啊多年以后我来看这个视频啊就多年以后我已经是stuff了然后来翻这个视频发现哦我以前居然说自己升不上我真是个蠢对吧对是外美金但是很早时候就他差不多16年可能1617年现在这不好算啊
就反两三百万吧你这么想吧因为现在股票这个股票的波动太大了真真不太好算然后真的胜不上那我真的真的真的有可能胜不上这个这个不是开玩笑我是真的觉得自己身上去很难因为相当的staff相当于要差不多p8了吧p8以上吧这个真的对公司没有点贡献的话是没有办法轻易升上去的你肯定是做点东西的主播回国动力是啥我我没有回国啊我本来就在国内好吧我没我我说的是
我的同事的情况就是美国的同事的情况不算股票60多万人民币你这咋算呢当年当年应该有差不多一比七多吧80几万对吧加上股票股票可能也有我不好说我忘记了我真的忘记了这是同事的情况我自己不真不记得了还有抽奖吗ef还有抽奖可以抽掉了还有抽奖啊你这边结束了是吧好的好的不一定结束我看大家有什么问题你先抽吧
对好的那那你这边先聊着对然后我们结束之前是还有最后一轮抽奖的然后我刚才去调了一下技术人现在之前应该已经活了所以想加群的可以去加一下然后我这边投一下评对